متابعه مع ضيفنا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد
الياس حنا اهلا بك في البدايه عن دلالات
استقبال الرئيس بوتين لقائد اركان فاجنرال
السابق تروشيب وتكليفه بتشكيل وحدات
قتاليه تؤدي مهام على الارض
مريم شكل الاجتماع هو دليل على ان من هو
المسؤول يعني نائب وزير الدفاع غياب وزير
الدفاع غياب رئيس الاركان
هو لديه الخبره السابقه هو كان في
هو قاتل في سوريا مع فاجنر وهو ايضا من
يقال انهما طرد من لانه سرب خبر مخطط
بيجوجين قبل التمرد فاذا انت تاتي لشخص
لديه خبره ومعرفه في الجهازيه الاساسيه
وكانه يقول بالشكل انا اتحدث مريم هؤلاء
هذان الشخصان مسؤولين عسكريا والامر الامر
ياتي من الكرملين يبقى الامر المهم مريم
ماذا سيجري في افريقيا يعني نتحدث عن
ديمتريستيف وهو شخص مسؤول عن كل الشركات
التي تعمل في افريقيا وهو شخص مهم جدا كان
مقربا من بريكوجين ماذا سيحصل له في
المستقبل
لكن ليش شكل العمليات القتاليه التي يمكن
ان يشرف عليها تروشيف
وما الذي يعنيه تكليفه في هذا التوقيت من
الحرب
يعني اعاده التجنيد اعاده التاهيل لهذه
القياده من يرغب بالقتال مع وزاره الدفاع
تحت هذه القياده الجديده ومن يرغب
بالانضمام الى شركات امنيه مختلفه
وبالتالي عمليه التنقيه للقتال وبشكل ان
يكون من ضمن هؤلاء الاشخاص مجموعه قد تسبب
مشاكل كما فعل بريجوجين نحن في مرحله
جديده ولكن السؤال دائما مريم هل سيكون
لها هذا التاثير كما حصل في مخلوط مع
بريجوجين لا اعتقد لماذا لانه وحده
القياده ولحمه القوات التي تقاتل مع بعضها
البعض امر مهم جدا خلال القتال العسكري
اثنين وهون هنا بيت القصير تغيرت
ديناميكيه وصوره الارض ان كان في مخموت او
حتى في اماكن اخرى ولكن هذا الامر يدل
مريم ايضا ان حاجه القوات الروسيه
ووزاره الدفاع الى قوات ذات خبره عاليه
ومهمه وهنا ياتي
يحدث هذا ايضا مع تزايد وتيره الهجمات
الاوكرانيه التي تستهدف عميد الياس حنا
الداخل الروسي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث
عن احباط هجوم اوكراني استهدف كالوجا
وكورسك كيف تقرا هذه الوتيره
هذه الوتيره يعني يدل ان هناك استراتيجيه
معينه وهذا ما تحدث عنه رئيس رئيس
المخابرات
الاوكرانيه العسكريه ايضا هذا الامر ينقل
الحرب الى الداخل الروسي يقول ان اوكرانيا
لديها مسيرات ليست غربيه وقادره على الضرب
بالداخل ولكن مريم يجب ان نركز اكثر على
ما يجري في شبه جزيره القرم التي حتى الان
لا يبدو ان وتيره الهجمات عليها قد خفت
وهذا ينظر يعني ينطلق او ينطبق من ضمن
استراتيجيه كبيره مهمه تعتمدها وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه العميد الياس حنا
الخبيره العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك